je l'aide cadiot bonjour vous êtes
historienne et directrice d'études à le
hss spécialistes la russie on le voit
les troupes russes progress en ukraine
mais elle rencontre des difficultés est
ce que l'opinion russe est un minimum
informés de ce qui se passe en ce moment
alors il est difficile de savoir
exactement d'abord qu'est-ce que cette
opinion russe puis public russe puisque
ça fait quand même des années que cette
opinion publique n'a plus d'accès ou un
accès très limité aux médias
indépendants donc comme on le sait
depuis le début du mois de mars à
travers un certain nombre de lois les
médias indépendants ont quitté la russie
je pense en particulier à la radio écho
moscou et qui a été démantelé puis la
télévision
rennes et donc les informations se
diffuse quand même elle se diffuse
encore par des réseaux familiaux il ya
encore des canaux télégramme ont des
choses se disent et mai mais il est
évident que le suivi au jour le jour de
ce qui se passe en ukraine et gravement
endommagé en particulier par le fait
qu'ils noah finale a été prise dès le 4
mars
2022 qui est extrêmement coûteuse pour
ce qu'ils enfreindraient donc c'est une
loi qui dit que toute diffusion de
nouvelles mensongère via vue vis-à-vis
de l'opération spéciale qui a lieu
actuellement mais aussi donc toute
falsification de ses nouvelles peut
mener a donc des poursuites pénales
extrêmement l'autre puisqu'elles vont
normalement d'amande mais jusqu'à 15 ans
d'emprisonnement
ce qui a fait en fait les faits c'est
toi c'est non seulement c'est sur les
russes il ya beaucoup de russes
d'activistes qui faisait ce travail
indépendant de médias souvent
assez bricoler qui partent qu'ils
essaient de partir et puis aussi
beaucoup de correspondants étrangers qui
du coup vont arrêter d'utiliser les
réseaux sociaux parce que eux-mêmes
peuvent être en danger donc ça crée un
climat extrêmement difficile pour
diffuser les informations même si
internet fonctionne encore et à bon il
ya plusieurs endroits ordu russie où les
informations se font et on a des
informations est ce qu est ce qu il ya
une opposition néanmoins parmi les
couches supérieures de la société russe
à cette guerre alors on sait qu'il ya
une opposition même très spontanés ils
m'ont été quand même les spécialistes
russie extrêmement extrêmement surpris
par le fait qu'ils aient autant de
manifestations au premier jour de la
guerre nous premiers jours de la guerre
il ya eu des manifestations le 6 mars
tout de même importante puisque
finalement il ya eu +2/4 14 me et
l'intérêt interpellation ce qui est
quand même vraiment beaucoup et surtout
ce qui est très intéressant c'était que
c'était pas simplement à moscou saint
pétersbourg mais aussi dans plus de 145
ville de russie donc c'est de la
fédération russe donc on
observe quand même un mouvement qui
avait déjà commencé avec
l'emprisonnement navalni d'une société
civile extrêmement courageuse qui qui
qui sort après on pense actuellement que
ce sera plutôt une espèce d'une forme
d'opposition à bas bruit avec des
graffitis des formes de performance anti
guerre qui permettent quand même
d'échapper
d'échapper à la poursuite pénale l'animé
poutine semble s'appuyer sur un fort
sentiment nationaliste et même des
sondages qui disent qu'il a pris des
points depuis le début de l'invasion on
parle de délation à la police des
personnes critique qu'en est il alors
sur ce thème de sentiments nationalistes
il faut toujours faire très attention
parce qu'en fait il ya des la propagande
d'état à des messages très que moi je
j'appellerais plutôt chauvin en fait
extrêmement violent contre contre la
direction ukrainienne on a aussi le
patriarche kirill café des serments
extrêmement violents appelant à la
guerre sainte parlant de nazis donc on a
on a ce premier vocabulaire qui fait
vraiment froid dans le dos et qui est
qui choque quand même beaucoup de russes
parce que c'est vrai que le régime de
vladimir poutine s'appuie aussi sur des
groupes
qu'on qualifierait en france d extrême
droite extrêmement conservateur est donc
très violente dans leur rhétorique les
propos justement de génocide de nazis
commencé perçue par les russes sont
elles discordance entre l'allée propre
la réalité a faim on a l'impression
qu'on parle d'une réalité de réalité
alternative en fait oui alors on
au niveau des russes en fait il y aurait
vraiment une très grande distinction à
faire entre d'une part une
intelligentsias où des classes moyennes
et qui sont en fait très polarisée ou
une partie et pro-occidentale plus tôt
et contre la guerre et une partie en
effet qui face à la propagande
médiatique de poutine est beaucoup plus
réceptives et la propagande de poutine
est aussi plus complexe que ça parce que
quand on regarde la télé actuellement
elle dit aussi qu'elle mène une
opération humanitaire est là toute cette
construction de deux ukrainiens et de
l'otan comme des ennemis elles se
présentent comme des frères qui vont
aider les ukrainiens donc même des
personnes qui seraient moins moins
violentes peuvent aussi se retrouver
dans le discours quotidien qui est plus
qui est extrait voilà qui est mais qui
n'est pas tant que ça nationaliste et
c'est vrai que moi je verrais plutôt
c'est plutôt du côté ukrainien et je ne
dirais pas nationaliste on a en france
et un vocabulaire très élargie pour
parler de ses sentiments je parle plutôt
de patriotisme c'est à dire le
patriotisme et craignent un on le
ressent comme un choix aussi politique
vise à bina régime et en leur sens aussi
chez les ch et des russophones de
manière extrêmement claire parmi les
soldats russes là qui envahissent
l'ukraine en ce moment est ce que vous
savez quel est le pourcentage des
conscrits parce que eux ils ont des
liens avec n'a pas dit alors pour
l'instant on a juste quelques preuves
qui en a alors que ce n'est que ce
n'avait pas été du tout dit mais alors
ça c'est vraiment ça ça arrive par des
réseaux personnels en fait ça arrive
parle aussi des associations
kids d'observation des droits de l'homme
comme mauvais des infos qui il ya
quelques informations qui nous
parviennent comme quoi contrairement à
ce qu'ils aient ce qui a été dit c'est à
dire que ce serait que des contractuels
enfin une armée professionnelle
professionnel il y en a qui arrivent et
il ya quand même quelques canaux alors
sur évidemment des canaux cryptée enfin
qui sont sécurisées télégramme enfin
d'autres qui il ya des informations et
où ce travail en fait collecte des
données et fait il ça peut être un point
faible dans la politique
d'assujettissement de l'ukraine par
vladimir poutine alors évidemment on a
tous en mémoire ce qui s'est passé
surtout lors de la première guerre de
tchétchénie ou en fait c'est en
particulier cette association des maires
des soldats qui a eu 1 1 une influence
énorme
qui a permis d'informer le monde entier
sur ce qui se passait en tchétchénie
même si ça n'a pas changé las le cours
de la guerre il ya une seconde guerre de
tchétchénie après mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya des mots il ya la même chose
évidemment pour les mères de soldats et
les cercueils de plomb qui sont arrivés
de syrie donc hélas ces cadavres de
jeunes conscrits
sont des éléments qui nous permettent
d'être mieux informés de la guerre en
sachant que si les russes actuellement
très peur de la conscription il ya
beaucoup de familles russes qui veulent
quitter le pays aussi pour que leurs
enfants partent pas à la guerre et
comment a été perçu la déclaration par
vladimir poutine hier de faire appel à
des soi disant volontaires syrien alors
je
sais c'est difficile de savoir comment
la société russe on imagine bien que
certains segments trouvé ça formidable
mais que c'est pas il est beaucoup de il
est très difficile de parler de ces
personnes ultra nationaliste chauviniste
comme représentant la société russe
parce qu'on a même si vous avez cité des
sondages et les sondages disent que
alors ça dépend un médium et sans doute
les vannes a dit ce qu'il ya autour de
68 % de la population qui serait pour la
guerre en sachant qu'on crie mais
c'était 90 donc c'est quand même moins
mais ces sondages on sait très bien
qu'il ya une partie de la population la
moins éduquées la plus paupérisées qui
ne répond pas et où qui va répondre en
fait de manière stéréotypée conformiste
c'est à dire plus ou moins ce que le
pouvoir dit ça veut pas dire qu'elle ait
pas sceptique vis-à-vis de ce que dit le
pouvoir et on sait qu'il ya un très
grand scepticisme tous les enquêtes de
fond fait par les sociologues dans les
campagnes on sait que depuis quelque
temps il commençait à avoir de plus en
plus de scepticisme vis-à-vis de pouvoir
poutinien merci beaucoup juliette cadiot
d'être venu merci pour votre d'écrivain